[Music]
fao's
pharma field schools have improved the
skills of over 20 million
farmers pastoralists and fisherfolk in
over 90 countries
[Music]
by putting the farmers at the heart of
the learning and innovation process
farmer field schools empower people
households
and communities producers
meet regularly in their fields discuss
problems
innovations and management techniques
set up
experiments make weekly observations
and take joint decisions
they build a deeper understanding of the
local agro ecosystem
over the course of 30 years farmer field
schools
have grown to cover a wide range of
topics
including agroecological farming
agroecology is a holistic approach that
applies ecological
and social principles to the design and
management
of sustainable agriculture and food
systems
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
farmer field schools introduced by fao
in india
have been adapted to focus on
regenerating soil health
using intensive polycropping and
agroforestry
locally made by a stimulants derived
from animals
and botanical pesticides
every week groups of 20 to 25 producers
from the same village
meet on their pharma field school site
to do an agro ecosystem analysis
and monitor their experiments
[Music]
two subgroups of farmers monitor the
condition
of two priority crops while another
subgroup
can make visual assessments of soil
health
another group can check all the plants
and trees
present in a few square meters and
discuss the positive synergies
between the species which are growing
next to or
under each other they will observe which
trees will provide support for crops by
giving shade
wind breaks organic matter for soil
cover or compost
and fruit as farmer field school members
increase their plant diversity
throughout the year
nutrition and incomes also improve
and farms become more resilient to
extreme climate events
and outbreaks of pests such as the fall
army one
these regenerative agricultural
approaches
put into practice the concept of one
health
for ecosystems animals and people
agroecological principles are very
important because if we maintain the
diversity of crops on a piece of land
the diversity of microbes and beneficial
insects also increases
hence no need of putting fertilizers and
manures and
other pesticides and chemicals and all
from outside
so we can recycle the nutrients that is
from the field
to animals or livestock and from the
livestock we can give directly to this
field so we are here
to explain about agroecological
principles the diversity
uh the recycling procedure and
the economic economic principles like
year round income
the ffs people are like a group of
people no caste no religious basis and
they're happy now
[Music]
the discovery learning process in farmer
field schools
is ideal to support farmers learning and
innovation on agroecology
and offer a practical pharma-driven
approach
to discover and regenerate the complex
web of life
sustaining our agro ecosystems
[Music]
you